(hip hop instrumentals)
- Hey everybody.
Welcome to the first #AskGaryVee.
I think it's the first one,
but I actually do think I tried
to do this once before.
I feel like I've got the team now in place
to actually do this more often.
Here we go.
(hip hop instrumental beats)
Joe, you know, the long tail just moving
the goal post is an
interesting kind of question.
You're asking a very
interesting question of
a very specific character, meaning
I am so long term.
I am so by the Jets that the stuff
in between is less important.
Every decision I make from
VaynerMedia to deciding
to write books, to speaking,
to doing this right now
is predicated on how does that chess move
to meet actually owning the Jets one day.
I'll tell you what I think about this.
I understand the thesis and the question.
The tone is often lost on Twitter.
I think I know where
you're going which is cool.
You can have a big picture, but if you're
not executing properly in the short term
do you actually get there?
To me it's actually the reverse.
I find that one of the
biggest reasons I'm able
to build big businesses,
make smart investments.
I'm now on my second business
that I've operated from
a small base to a huge base
in one second is because when you have a
big picture in mind, a North Star,
the long term vision,
something interesting happens,
and I'm gonna get close here, Joe.
You stop
you stop stressing the dumb little shits
day in and day out, because you're playing
the big game.
What happens is the short term angst,
which is really the friction of growth
actually becomes a little
bit more manageable,
a little easier to deal with,
and I have found by
having those big visions
I'm moving the short
goal post moves quicker,
faster, more importantly.
I'm one of these pro
go all in, deep, big long-term vision.
Calculate towards it at all times,
and you'll find that being 85% effective
in your short term moves, because you're
110% effective and focused
on your long term goal
is actually moving you
quicker along the way.
(hip hop instrumental beats)
Look digi talk, I feel
like the first fax owner
everyday of my life.
Can you imagine how I feel?
I'm usually really at the
forefront of these things.
You know, I'm gonna give you a very simple
piece of advice.
I try not to convert anyone
from all the pieces of
content, from all the T-shirts
we make, show Zak.
They'll like that he made the T-shirt.
From all the things I do, the quote cards,
the keynotes, the books,
the ranting and raving, these videos.
Truth is, I don't give a crap
about converting one person.
I'm only speaking to the converted.
If your market hasn't moved yet,
and they don't believe in fax machines,
and you're trying to sell a fax machine.
Don't try to convince
somebody to buy a fax machine.
Go find the people that already
have bought into the fax machine, and just
sell it to them, because
if you're too early
in a theory or a business where nobody
has bought in, you've lost.
For everybody who thinks I'm Nostradamus
or I'm far ahead, the
truth is I'm not far ahead
I'm just practical and
realize there's enough scale
in the reality of 2014
right now marketing.
There's enough people buying in
to make it practical,
and there was even enough
in 2009 when I started
VaynerMedia with A.J.,
when nobody thought I was
ready or the market was ready,
or anybody was ready.
There was just enough for us
to actually build a business,
and then we grew into it.
We skated to where the puck was gonna be,
as that classic statement is,
and so that's my answer.
Don't try to convert anybody.
Don't waste energy on people
that can't consume it.
Just go on the full offense on the people
that have already bought in.
(hip hop instrumental beats)
As building audiences
on Pinterest and YouTube
with Facebook dark posts
is the wrong strategy
in a world where you can
build YouTube audience
with pre rolls at five
to seven cents a view,
and Pinterest is about
20 seconds away from
their ad platform.
My answer to you is
it's nice to try to siphon.
I do think Facebook dark
posts will probably be
the most effective besides
the native way to do it,
but if you're trying to build
YouTube and Pinterest audience
I highly recommend doing
it with the native app
platforms within those
two principal parties.
(hip hop instrumental beats)
BennyMod, when I buy the New York Jets
I will become the kind of owner that makes
Mark Cuban and Jerry Jones seem passive.
Not only will I probably
touch personnel decisions,
there's a dark horse
chance that you'll hear,
"And starting at wide receiver
number five, Gary Vanyerchuk"
I will reshape
the mold of ownership in
American sports history.
(hip hop instrumental beats)
Dragga, you know,
honestly I don't know why
Steve, show them.
I don't know why Steve
picked this question,
because the truth is
there's not enough context.
How do we apply it to your music world?
I don't know.
What do you do?
Do you put on shows?
It's easy.
Do you sell T-shirts or pants?
Easy, do you try to resell music?
A little tricky.
I'll need a little more context.
I'm gonna allow you to
retweet with more context,
and we'll get you back on the show.
(hip hop instrumental beats)
Kev, first of all, I'm
so ridiculously jealous
that you're 21.
It makes me wanna vomit on myself.
I always say that I'd give up everything
to be 21, and I mean it.
The knowledge would be tough to give up,
but I think I mean it.
Time is the asset.
I wrote a piece about
what I would do if I was
a real estate agent on
Linked In about Twitter.
Be in the links.
Searching on Twitter is gold,
and then just putting out content.
There's some guy early on in 2009
when I wrote Crush It!
who completely jumped
on it, and crushed it as
a real estate agent putting
like a flip cam on his car
while he drove, but the truth is
it's putting out content
and it's using Twitter
as an offense.
Enjoy.
(hip hop instrumental beats)
Evan, you're not selling a hard product,
and I paid attention to how
you frameworked your question,
but the truth is ultimately Evan,
I think you're trying to play chess to get
a donation.
I will tell you that the number one sector
in social media that is
most struggled in my opinion
is non-profit and NGO.
The amount of people,
because I have over a million
followers on Twitter that
hit me up everyday, everyday.
15 people a day on Twitter that hit me up
for can you give to charity?
Can you retweet this for our charity?
Without even saying hello.
Can you romance a girl?
It makes no sense.
The way you do it.
The way you sell that culture is look,
there's Charity: Water as the
gold standard in my opinion
of heavy story telling through content.
I would look at that as a model.
It's about putting out good content.
It's about engaging with people
around their issues.
It's searching the terms,
much like the last question,
around whatever you're
trying to solve and jumping
into conversations.
It's about effort, instead of, you know,
there's an entitlement
on the non-profit NGO
space that needs to be broken
for them to be successful
in an open, transparent one-on-one world
where it's not guilting
or relying on what people
think they have to give.
I had dinner last night
with a CEO of a major
NGO non-profit, and I
said I feel great giving
back, and he said, no stop.
Get rid of the word back.
It's just good giving.
By saying giving back it's
like you've taken something,
and it really was powerful.
I think we need to get to a place where
it's not what's expected.
It's what's appreciated, and
that can be completely executed
on social better than any other place,
because it's transparent.
It's open.
Get into conversations.
Show the effort.
Romance a girl.
Execute.
My friends, I'm excited about this
as you can see there's
very attractive people
assoicated with this organization,
and I think we're gonna
be doing it more often
especially because the man behind the mic,
DRock is now here,
and I feel like we got this.
I will be tweeting out more questions.
Use the hashtag anytime you want.
You know, and I'll see you later.
(hip hop instrumental beats)